[Music]
but the action of conscience is not only
this determination of being which is
forsaken by the pure self what is to be
valid and to be recognized as duty
is so only through the knowledge and
conviction that it is duty
through the knowledge of itself in the
deed if the deed ceases to have this
self within it it ceases to be that
which
alone is its essence its existence
forsaken by this consciousness
would be an ordinary reality and the
action would appear to us to be the
fulfilling of one's pleasure and desire
what ought to be there is here in
essentiality solely by its being known
to
be the self-expression of an
individuality
and it is this being known that is
acknowledged by others
and which as such ought to have an
existence
paragraph 650 is a rather short one but
there's
a lot going on in this paragraph
and in the two other shorter ones
that follow so it begins by
saying the action of conscience is not
only
this determination of being which is
forsaken
by the pure self and and that's
you know a reference to something that
we've seen running throughout this
discussion
of morality and we're going to see it
appear once again
we've got the action that's being taken
and without action duty doesn't really
mean anything if it's just something
pure abstract out there kind of in the
ether
and nobody's actually doing anything
and and not just doing anything in the
sense of
one action you know what we're
translating here is
the deed the tot right the the single
thing that's being done but a course of
action condom a comportment a set of
behavior
a commitment you might even say
through what it is that one does through
the attitudes that one
events now whenever that's coming up we
have
essentially two sides to it at least
in in hegel's discussion and these
correspond you know pretty well to
what's happening
in post-conscience philosophy kant of
course you know
what matters is the formal aspects of
the action the maxim
you know what it is that you're doing in
the most general way you actually want
to
try to avoid as much as possible
considering the particulars the
you know the determinate stuff who you
happen to be
because insofar as you start looking at
that you realize how conditioned
the action is the fact that it it's
driven by
intentions or motivations or drives
or whatever we want to call it that are
particular to the person that
would call pathological and you don't
have to be a conscient
in order to to grasp this sort of thing
as a matter of fact
himself says that that this is something
that the ordinary person ought to be
able to understand i'm just trying to
articulate it
a little bit more clearly
so there's this this formal and in
hegel's view
sort of free but empty side to
pure side to pure thought
and here this is going to be tied in
with pure
conscience right the the pure self
as we're going to see talked about in in
the next paragraph even more
and then we've got the actual messy
empirical person who's doing
the stuff and they're both sides of the
same
thing right and so conscience
itself is acting
and determining being and this like he
says
is forsaken by the pure
self and then he's got this next
sentence that i thought was really
important
to highlight what is to what it is to be
what is to be valid and to be recognized
as
duty is so only through the knowledge
and conviction that it is duty
and then he says through the knowledge
of oneself in the deed we're going to
come back to that
in a moment but let's think about this
for a moment what it is to be valid
so in german geltin to to
you know be able to pass to be worth
something to have some sort of
value to it that can be recognized
and then to be actually acknowledged
or recognized in the sense
now when when hegel is using this on-air
cannon it's usually about
people recognizing each other but people
recognize each other
he doesn't mean in the sense of like
saying oh across the crowded room that's
joe
over there drinking that beer or hey
that's priscilla in the supermarket or
anything
along those lines or recognizing a piece
of music
he's talking about recognition
as acknowledging the
agency the personhood maybe in some
respects the equality or at least the
reciprocity
between oneself and another person
and these two things are connected
together you know
gelatin being valid being worth
something and
being recognized or recognizing
so here it's the duty that's actually
going to be recognized he uses the the
german word
verdun there right so it's not yet
recognized
what is to be recognized as as duty
now who's doing the recognition well
this is where it gets quite
interesting so on the one hand it is
conscience
and it's relation to itself
the person who is acting on the basis of
conscience
is recognizing the duty but the duty is
something that's coming
out of them so in a way they're
recognizing themselves
and they're also being recognized by the
others remember just a few paragraphs
before hegel started talking about being
for others in the paragraph just prior
to this
he was saying that others don't know
whether this conscience is morally good
or evil uh they must take it to be evil
in this
in this paragraph they're actually not
doing that they're kind of giving it the
benefit of the doubt again
so let's go on now here we get to the
real crux of it
in the the second part of the second
sentence
is so only through the knowledge and
conviction that it
is duty through the knowledge of oneself
in the deed how does
one know oneself in the
action that one is taking and you might
say well how can there be any confusion
about that
it's my action i know exactly what i'm
doing
really aren't there so many things that
you have done without realizing
precisely what it was that you were
doing
until afterwards and some other pointed
it out and said man you're screwing up
why did you do that stupid thing so it's
not quite so straightforward is it
as a matter of fact conscience does have
to get to know
itself through what it's it's engaging
in
so he says if the deed ceases to have
this self within it whatself
the pure self if the deed doesn't
have that within it then what happens
it ceases to be that which alone is its
essence so we're you know we're drawn to
this
again formal characteristic of the
action
i realize myself as not just doing
things because i'm a selfish bastard
or because i'm you know in love with
this person over here or because i have
this particular background
or because of some other more
particular determination but because
it's the right thing to do
i recognize it as the right thing to do
i
am to some degree the pure self and
hegel thinks that this is a
possibility for any geist any spirit any
mind that has reached this point and i
think he would also be willing to
backtrack it
into less developed or previous states
of
shapes of consciousness as well
so he says that its existence
forsaken by this consciousness would be
an
ordinary reality and the action
would appear to us to be to now notice
appear to us
to be the fulfilling of one's pleasure
and desire so
and we can substitute other things there
it could be the fulfillment of one's
revenge it could be the fulfillment of
one's brainwashed duty
and one's willingness to follow rules or
one's people-pleasing or whatever it
happens to be
it would be conditioned it would be
particular it would be to a certain
extent unfree
in its own free seeming action
because something else is is driving
us this is the difference here between
essence vasen and existence daz
right so both of these are involved
in the action which leads to the deed
and the duty right the deed and the duty
the taught and the
are in some respect uh flip sides of the
same
coin now
so we've got a conflict right and we've
got a possibility of choosing one over
the other
and then he says what ought to be there
is here an essentiality solely
by its being known to be the
self-expression
of an individuality what i want to be
there
is an essentiality solely by
meaning the others play a constitutive
role in this
it's being known to be the
self-expression of an individuality i
look at the action that's being done
by so and so and i say that's their
action
that the tokens the kind of person that
they are
what not just what their motivational
structure is
but whether they allow their
motivational structure to determine it
or whether they are following something
that is
higher but also more formal and empty
or pure they have the choice
they are the individuality deciding that
right so it's not just deciding between
different motives
it's deciding whether to allow these
motives these individualistic
motives to determine things or not
and then he says that's what ought to be
there right it's not necessarily what
actually is there
so he says it is this being known that
is
acknowledged by others and which
as such ought to have an existence
so what has existence is this
tawdry you know you're like everybody
else and that you've got your own
individual motives
but what ought to be there what ought to
have existence is
instead this higher self you might say
a pure self that is choosing
the duty as a way in which it it knows
its own self
the self enters into existence as self
the self assured spirit exists as such
for others its immediate action is not
that which has validity
and is actual what is acknowledged is
not the determinant aspect of the action
not its intrinsic being
but solely the self-knowing self as such
the element of lasting being is the
universal self-consciousness
what enters into this element cannot be
the effect of the action
the effect cannot endure in it and
acquires no permanence
it is only self-consciousness that is
acknowledged
and that obtains an actual existence
this short paragraph 651 continues the
movement begun
in paragraph 650 or
let's say the the heavy distinction the
highlighting of this this bifurcation
within the self and its
action in relation to duty so the moral
self of what we might call the
empirical and the ideal sides if we
wanted to use somebody else's
terminology
hegel here is going to talk about the
difference between
the self-knowing pure self
and this this motivated
individual acting self which are both
what we are
what's of interest here though is not
the unity of
action but rather what is going to be
recognized what is going to be
acknowledged by
the others and thereby by
oneself what is it that conscience
is grasping itself as no longer now
potentially evil or actually evil
but as something that it would take to
be
good or at least how things
ought to be so there's this wonderful
line beginning it
where hegel says that the self and by
this he means the pure self right
the zelps that was talked about in the
previous passages
steps into existence as
self now steps into existence is quite
literal here but is worth dwelling on
for a moment
so steps right takes a step
into existence how do you step into
existence into design and here we might
be tempted to you know bring in
heidegger and say well dozen is not just
you know existence but rather
being there and okay that that helps a
little bit but we're not talking about a
spatial
location we're not even talking about a
temporal location which heidegger was
really great
in describing and unpacking for us you
know being at the heart of being and
fundamental ontology put all that aside
for a moment
design being there what is the there
the there is the moral
space that of importance
that of value something that by the way
heidegger was not very good at handling
because he was much more interested in
other aspects of phenomena
so being
there existing standing out
you know if we use if we go back to the
latin term existed which i think is
worthwhile doing here
in this case when we see
before the high middle ages when people
got really bogged down and the
difference between essay and
essentia and existencia and all of these
sorts of things
when they were using the term in a bit
more fluid way
they would use the term existed
or exist it for for the
the you know uh indiv for the the
individual thing that's doing
the existing by contrast in a way
to to being but rather not as like a
different mode of being but as an
intensification
so for example you might not know this
if you've only read it in the english
translation or whatever other language
if you haven't read anselm's so-called
ontological argument and prosologian ii
in latin you wouldn't actually know this
that he changes the language that he's
using from
deus essa god is or has being
to deus existed
existed actually
god in god's existence stands out so
stepping into existence is like
coming into prominence it's like
i mean we could use heidegger here it's
like coming out of concealment alathea
in in the old notion of truth
so the pure self steps into a kind of
prominence of existence it steps into
a way of existing that says here i am
and how is it able to do that it's able
to do that
because of the others supporting it
because it has the others already in a
certain respect
connected with and perhaps even within
it
giving it you know its its chorus
or its support or something like that
and that's happening in what what
here hegel is calling universal
self-consciousness so there's a lot
wrapped up in this first phrase the self
enters
into existence as self immediately after
that he says the self-assured spirit
exists as such for others it does not
exist
solely on its own as a thought
thinking itself it exists within a world
that is populated by others
which are others like itself others that
have all of this complex dynamic
going on within themselves others that
have all of this
empirical stuff individual stuff
motives drives on their own part
relationships
that they exist within and yet each one
of them
also has this pure self
within it and that is what's doing the
recognition here
so he says the self-assured spirit
exists as such for others it's immediate
action
is not that which has validity and is
actual it's immediate action or
mitsubara
right so it's not just un immediate like
what it's doing
just right now it's action considered
without mediation just as sort of like a
bear
fact right um
and he goes on and he says what is
acknowledged what is anarchand
right this key thing running throughout
the entire
hegelian dialectic and development on
air cannon
what is acknowledged is not the
determinate the
dashboard here it's the determinant
aspect of the action the german is a
little bit more direct
you know not its intrinsic being
again miller is a little bit misleading
it's on zigzag
it's anxiety aspect right um
but solely the self-knowing self
as such so when you say
the self-knowing self as such you've got
kind of an
intensified relation a reflexive
relation
going on there even though it's this
pure self what is it doing
it's self knowing right it's so it's
it's in a relation to itself
already as the kind of thing that it is
and then
as such that is what is being
recognized here i'm gonna i almost said
talked about here
but that's projecting a little bit ahead
to the next paragraph so i'm going to
set that aside for a moment
he goes on and he says the element of
lasting being blabenda what remains
what what what is able to stay over time
the elements of lasting being is the
universal self-consciousness
now notice what he says here he doesn't
say say universal spirit
he doesn't say the universal reason he
doesn't say the universal consciousness
the universal
self-consciousness we're going back
again to that whole self-consciousness
section
which definitely was not you know summed
up in
in master and slave but only started off
with that
and we're seeing this this dialectic of
recognition
playing its central role being developed
being being worked out
further in this morality section of
spirit
so he says uh what enters into this
element cannot be the effect
the vehicle of the action that's this
stuff over here
provided by the individual empirical
particular
self right the effect cannot endure in
it and acquires no permanence
no blimey it is only self-consciousness
that is acknowledged and that obtains an
actual existence
now self-consciousness is
in some respects a little bit more
loosey-goosey in hegel
than consciousness or reason right
it's harder to pin down exactly what
self-consciousness
is this is why so many people if they've
actually followed their hegel
realize that the self-consciousness
section really is quite important it
sets the stage
but then everything within it is being
worked out and we're getting almost to
the end of it here
in the morality section
so the self enters into existence as
self that is what we're going to be
looking at
now as what is being acknowledged the
one last thing i want to point out
is that hegel here is talking primarily
about
the self-knowing self being acknowledged
as you know through universal
self-consciousness by others
it's worth remembering that every one of
these others
is also hungering
right desires at the bottom of
self-consciousness for
that that recognition as well we don't
want to slip into
a sort of selfish one-sided recognition
any more than we did in the master slave
dialectic
here again then we see language as the
existence of spirit
language is self-consciousness existing
for
others self-consciousness which as such
is immediately present and this
self-consciousness is universal
it is the self that separates itself
from itself which as
pure i equals i becomes objective
to itself which in this objectivity
equally preserves itself
as this self just as it coalesces
directly with other selves and is their
self-consciousness it perceives itself
just as it is perceived by others
and the perceiving is just existence
which has become
a self
when we're thinking about linguistic
philosophy philosophy of language
philosophy even that's attentive to
language
we don't typically think that much about
hegel
as such although we often do think about
people
influenced by hegel don't we
but here in this passage in paragraph
652 we begin some
interesting reflections about language
and how it works and for hegel language
is indeed tied in with the structure of
self-consciousness so he tells us
we see language spraka as the existence
design of spirit
right these are some important
declarations on the part of hengel
especially since he just talked about
the self
stepping into existence how is it
stepping into existence
it's not as if first has stepped into
existence with its act or something like
that
he's describing a process and attending
the different moments of it
so language is already there as what is
allowing
the acting subject to be able to
conceive what their action is going to
be
for others to recognize it you know
robbing a gas station
that happens in language just as much as
it happens
in we might say the real viewer click
world
where somebody points a gun at somebody
else and says give me your money
says signifies all of this is happening
within not language itself as in the
there's nothing else
you know there's there's nothing but
language there's a big difference
there's a little bit of a digression
when people were criticizing darida for
saying
there is no outside of the text right
or text right people got really worked
up about that i remember
somebody coming up to me in graduate
school and saying you think there's
nothing but language everything is
language
and i looked at him and i was like who
the hell thinks that
nobody who's doing linguistically
informed philosophy actually believes
that it's all just language like we're
in one sort of
you know idealistic simulation
no the point is that you're never going
to get away from language because
language is already there
doing stuff behind the scenes and you're
using it even to frame the complaint
that you're making that's a little bit
of a
more realistic way of talking about it
hegel's pointing at this right here
right the self that exists that comes
into existence
does so through language language
as the existence of spirit so
he's not giving us his full theory of
language here or anything like that i
mean
in order to get a theory of language out
of hegel you'd have to actually
do the philosophical detective work of
taking you know passages from here and
there and cobbling together
them together and there are philosophers
who have done that
in the 20th century john mccumber would
be a great example of that
in his little known work on hegel and
language in any case he says that
language is self-consciousness
but he doesn't say language is
self-consciousness
as such self-consciousness
existing for others
in the german right and that's right
there at the very start of that phrase
language is for others existing
self-consciousness
if we're looking at the lexical order
what does that mean language is
revealing to us a very important aspect
of self-consciousness
hegel thinks you can't have
self-consciousness all by itself anyway
it doesn't make sense self-consciousness
always has
the other involved with it even if it
killed off every single other in the
universe it would still
have those others haunting it language
is
part of the way that happens
so he goes on and he says language is
self-consciousness existing for others
right
and self-consciousness which
as such i hear he says a couple
interesting things
is immediately present and this
self-consciousness
is universal okay so how is language
present at every point here's where we
really need to go beyond the text and
think about what
you know modern linguistics has told us
about language language
is in fact like a network or a structure
that is never completely finished and
yet exists
at every point and that's why we can
actually speak
a language and go from language to
language
right so within we might call it capital
l
language and all of this is possible
because
in a certain sense it's virtually
present at every point
it's also universal one of the insights
that hegel has is when you make
something
into a word you do start to invoke the
universal even if you say something like
this particular thing that's interesting
isn't it
which which particular thing do you mean
this particular thing
or this particular thing
or this particular thing see
words like particular are actually quite
general
aren't they right and we don't want to
get all platonic or
deconstructionists and say oh they're
you know so therefore they're not pure
anything no
we have to work with them that's that's
the language that we have to work with
same thing with action right action
handle
behavior that's a very very general term
that we've been using as we're going
through this entire section in the
phenomenology
and yet it applies to this action right
here of me putting out my hand and now
closing it and now pointing at you all
of those
are instances there's a universal there
you see what i'm saying now he goes on
and he says that uh language and here's
you know he's being a little
metaphorical right
it's the self that separates itself from
itself
which as pure i equals i becomes
objective to itself
which in this objectivity equally
preserves itself
as this self just as and we're going to
stop
right there because this is like going
on and he's adding it it's like he's
throwing everything in there
and then putting one more ingredient on
top of the pizza
sometimes it can be a little bit much
now let's attend to the things that he
said
i'm going to come back to the self
separating itself all that verbiage in a
second the i
equals i so this is pure identity right
but it's an identity
that realizes itself as identity and
here it becomes objective the word
objective
is translating gigan lika gegen
against right things that are being set
apart from each other so the i
equals i is not a fusion but rather a
separation out into things that are the
same
but now are opposing each other that's
part of the notion of objectivity here
so then he says um in this objectivity
it equally preserves itself
as this self right that's what allows it
to have what in the last paragraph was
talked about as
remaining or staying there blibenda
right
so that's important now let's attend to
this
little passage the self that separates
itself from itself
zeke fonzix alps
slicing off pushing away
so there is a self that is
taking itself and slicing or
cutting off separating that self
from itself you might say
how the hell do you do that well this is
something that we do all the time
without realizing hegel's just put a
name to it hegel's just brought it into
language
so the other thing that's important here
he says that it coalesces directly with
other selves and is their
self-consciousness this doesn't mean
that the individual person is coalescing
with other selves
language is doing that language
spreads itself out not just within me
but you
and all the rest of us that speak this
language
and understand it so here hegel talks
about perception for naaman he says
it perceives itself just as it is
perceived by others and the perceiving
is just
existence which has become a self fair
name and
grasping another way of talking about
apprehending
what's important here is that hegel is
reinforcing that
what we might call the linguistic self
what can be talked about
is now becoming how i know
myself and that is not just coming with
how i name myself
and to go a little bit back my actions
my motivations
my basic structure of character and all
of that
it's also how the others are
interpreting
me and how they're naming me
you